in this video we're going to talk about
powers
of
zero
and just as a little bit of a reminder
let's start with a non-zero number just
to remind ourselves what exponentiation
is all about
so if i were to take 2
to the first power
one way to think about this is we always
start with a one and then we multiply
this base that many times times that one
so here we're going to have one two so
it's going to be one times 2 which is of
course equal to 2. if i were to say what
is 2 to the second power well that's
going to be equal to
1
times and now i'm going to have two twos
so times 2 times 2 which is equal to 4.
and you could keep going like that
now the reason why i have this 1 here
and we've done this before is to justify
and there's many other good reasons why
2 to the zero power should be equal to
one but you could see if we use the same
exact idea here you start with a one
and then you multiply it by
two zero times well that's just going to
end up with
a one
so so far i've told you this video is
about powers of zero but i've been doing
powers of two so let's focus on zero now
so what do you think zero to the first
power is going to be pause this video
and try to figure that out
well you do the exact same idea you
start with a one and then multiply it by
zero one time
so
times zero and this is going to be equal
to zero
what do you think zero to the second
power is going to be equal to pause this
video and think about that
well it's going to be 1
times 0 twice
so
times
0 times 0 and i think you see where this
is going this is also going to be equal
to zero
what do you think
zero
to
some arbitrary positive
positive
integer
is going to be
well it's going to be equal to 1 times 0
that positive integer number of times so
once again it's going to be equal to 0.
and in general you can extend that 0 to
any positive value exponent is going to
give you zero so that's pretty
straightforward
but there is an interesting edge case
here
what do you think zero to the zeroth
power should be pause this video and
think about that
well this is actually contested
different people will tell you different
things if you use the intuition behind
exponentiation that we've been using in
this video you would say all right i
would start with a one and then multiply
it by zero zero times or in other words
i just wouldn't multiply it by zero in
which case i'm just left with the one
that zero to the zero power should be
equal to one
other folks would say hey no i'm with a
zero and that's the zeroth power maybe
it should be a zero and that's why a lot
of folks leave it undefined
most of the time you're going to see
zero to the zero power either being
undefined or that it is equal to 1.